the european union has kept its word and  has delivered  our target was to protect 70 of adults  in the european union with at least one  dose  in a vaccination in july today we have  achieved this target  and 57 of adults already have the full  protection  of double vaccination so these figures  put europe among the world leaders  the catch-up process has been very  successful  but we need to keep up the effort  the delta variant is very dangerous  and i therefore call on everyone who has  the opportunity  to be vaccinated for their own health  and to protect others and rest assured  the european union will continue to  provide sufficient volumes of vaccines